- [Instructor] So let's
see if we can come up ways
to compute what 2.8 times 4.73 is.
So pause this video,
and try to work it out.
And, actually, I'll give you a hint.
Try to figure out, just using the digits,
not even paying attention to the decimals,
the digits that the product would have,
and then use estimation to think about
where to place the decimal in your product
so you get a reasonable answer.
All right, now, let's do this together.
So let's just imagine
that we were multiplying
these numbers without decimals.
So that would be a situation
where we would have 473 times 28,
and so we could try to compute that.
And, so, we could think about
let's multiply everything
times the eight, so
three times eight is 24,
seven times eight is 56, plus two is 58.
And then four times eight
is 32, plus five is 37.
And then we could multiply
everything times the two.
I'll cross those out so
I don't get confused.
Three times two is going to be six,
so we have to be very careful,
we are now in the tens place,
so we want a zero here,
so three times two tens
is going to be six tens.
Seven times two is 14.
Four times two is eight, plus one is nine.
We add everything together,
and we get four plus zero is four,
eight plus six is 14,
and then one plus seven plus four is 12,
and then we get one plus three is four,
plus nine is equal to 13.
So we know that the final
answer has the digits one,
three, two, four, four in that order.
One, three, two, four, four.
So now we have to think about
where would we put a decimal
for this to be a reasonable answer?
And here's where estimation is useful.
We know that 2.8 times 4.73
is going to be roughly equal to what?
Well, 2.8 is pretty close to three,
so I'll estimate 2.8 as being three.
And 4.73 is, if I had to estimate,
I would say, "Hey, it'd
be pretty close to five."
So this should be pretty
close to three times five,
so it should be close to 15.
So if I were to put the decimal there,
that's way more than 15, so
that doesn't seem reasonable.
Even if I were to put the decimal there,
1,324.4 is still way more than 15.
If I were to put the decimal there,
still way more than 15.
hey, that actually feels about right.
13 and 244 thousandths is,
is approaching 15, it's in the ballpark.
And it's actually the closest,
'cause if we were to
put the decimal there,
then we go to 1.3244,
so a lot less than 15.
So if we want this to
be roughly equal to 15,
we definitely would wanna put
the decimal right over there.
That is the most reasonable
computation we can do,
'cause we know the digits
are going to be one,
three, two, four, four,
and this helps us put the decimal.
In the future, we're
gonna come up with ways
of doing it that where
you don't necessarily
have to estimate, but I encourage you,
the estimation is always key.
If you ever in your life
forget some type of method
or process for multiplying decimals,
it's the estimation that
allows you to understand
whether you're coming up
with a reasonable answer.
This is really important,
'cause the decimal, there's a,
I remember reading a news
story a couple years ago
where someone put in a stock trade
where they got the decimal wrong.
And because of that, they
essentially sold 10 times
as many shares as they were supposed to,
and so they lost hundreds
of millions of dollars.
So, anyway, decimals are important.